john travolta's daughter ella is showing  off her stunning vocals as she prepares  to release new music uh yeah ella shared  a clip of her original song and teased  her upcoming ep writing there is  something i've been working on for the  past year that is very dear to my heart  i wanted to share a part of a song that  i wrote that will be on my ep coming out  next year very excited hope you like it  yeah and of course her dad couldn't be  prouder taking to the comments to cheer  on his daughter writing this i'm so very  proud of you ella it's amazing you're  thrilled dad well take it away bye ross  ain't no sunshine when you're gone  i guess bill was fired when he wrote  that song  i know that she's your light  now  [Music]  i know  so hard when you make  fun of me though i can't make you happy  and i know that  yeah  that i forget  get a little bit  they say  a  [Music]  is  [Music]